Well, it looks at first
glance like ancient art is
actually a full blown Britain
language,
but what does this homegrown Mesoamerican
script teach us about the history of
writing?
I elaborate Rosa
characters onto a stealer.
A tall stone brought in from far away
that's now standing straight up in the
middle of the city.
The characters he's carving.
Look more like detailed pictures than
writing, but don't let that fool you.
Take a look at this block. It
means mountain, but it's not.
Although the graph standing for mountain,
it's not a rebus symbol. Brewer,
think of a word that rhymes
with [inaudible] mountain.
It's actually a block of two sound
symbols that spell the word [inaudible].
The [inaudible] word for mountain.
That's great for climbers,
but chocolate lovers may instead prefer
to sampled these three symbols that
together though the word to cow cocoa,
there's a nifty shortcut here.
This bit doesn't even mean car.
It's actually a syllable
multiplier or iteration mark,
if you want the fancy name.
Sure.
I think you're being watched
over there in the jungle.
Maybe not.
Hmm.
Major moments in the history of
writing both of these Maya glyphs,
combined syllable characters
into blocks to write words.
This is full fledged sound writing.
These are Loga graphs that happened
to be read as sounds. They are sounds,
sounds capable of writing any syllable
and the language in a full syllabary like
the classical Maya script.
There are separate characters for just
about every possible syllable in the
language.
No longer must have been meant.
New Word characters you can make do
with a much smaller set of syllable
characters.
Nice,
but syllable writing comes
with its own set of problems.
Here's a cliff that's quite
useful around these parts. Jaguar,
the word is actually belong,
but have you noticed something about the
Mayan syllabary consonant plus vowel,
consonant plus bowel,
more consonants plus more vowels.
All of these syllables,
Indian vowels.
How in the world are you supposed
to write the Lum in Balaam,
shifty, scripty syllabi
areas have grappled with this
problem and settled on two
solutions. One, leave
out the final letter.
Just ignore it.
The term for this is under spelling
because you're not fully spelling the word
and it's a good solution because you
know ignoring your problems makes them go
away. Option to spell the last
letter with an extra syllable,
but use a syllable that just repeats the
last vowel so that we know we can just
ignore the final vowel.
This gets called the echo vowel.
Mayan likes number two a lot.
So the cow is Kako wa well,
because times to Wa wheats,
the mountain is actually we see.
And your new pet Balaam is spelled Bala.
Ma.
Cross out the echo vowels and the
words practically read themselves.
Your new friend pulls you along
to show you another project.
He's working on an Amati Codex.
That's a paper book. Yes,
he has paper and yes books,
but that's not what's got him excited.
He folds open the book he's working
on maybe to share new ideas. No,
to brag about how inventive
and potentially efficient
his writing system is.
Know for his people.
The invention of the new
wasn't about ditching the old.
He shows you how creative he's been
with the characters you learned.
He shows you a mountain
and calls it weeds,
and then a Jaguar and calls
it Bilam low good graphs.
Wait a second,
you stop and ask him,
which is the correct way to write belong.
He writes Balama.
You ask him to write it again,
and he writes the logo graph,
but with the syllable and again,
but he writes the Loga
graph plus two syllables.
He smiles mischievously.
They're all below them.
This is what he's proud of.
He can write the same word,
even the same syllable in different
ways and combinations without repeating
himself creative, but his use of
logo graphs plus syllables or calls.
The tension between sound writing,
meaning writing meaningful, determinative,
helped us choose the right
pronunciation for our rebus character.
And my end Luga graphs can still do that,
but the helping hand goes both ways.
The syllabary can also clarify the sounds
you should make when you read a little
graph.
Here's the character Jaguar,
but at a couple extra syllable hints and
you make it clear that we're meant to
read this cliff as Bala Ma
minus the echo vowel. So Balaam.
These are phonetic compliments,
pronunciation, clis,
sitting comfortably alongside logo graphs.
If that's all too complex.
Just remember that you can
write everything in syllables,
but before you have time to settle
into this land of Balaam and Cacau to
practice those syllables, a sandy
wind starts blowing in from the east,
uh, familiar reminder from a faraway
land. We're even more dramatic.
Changes are about to shape
the future of writing.